[Applaudissements]
m
400 pages et pas une seule photo d'elle
à poil et le temps perdu bonjour
bertrand furno kevin week end sera super
week end où je m'en fous c'est une
formule de politesse
oui je réfléchis par week-end
aujourd'hui nous sommes lundi et le
lundi c'est que je parle usine j'adore
dans le lundi on passe à l'étape
supérieure
qu'est ce que vous allez faire vous
allez vous infiltrer dans les coulisses
ne touche pas à mon poste
objectif récolter un maximum
d'informations sur cyril hanouna de la
part des autres chroniqueurs les
dossiers des trucs salle afin que je
puisse le couler une bonne fois pour
toutes
ok en revanche ils connaissent le visage
est assez reconnaissable passe couvre
donc camou faire de petites moustaches
oui oui je vous confirme c'est toujours
diffusée le 28 mai 20 h 55 sur des huit
essais bibi qui présente oui allez
bisous
au lieu du mois
oh excusez moi laurent je sais pas ce
qui m'a pris je l'avais pas reconnu j'ai
une réaction chimique qui vous ressemble
tellement à 7 cette fille que j'ai connu
ses 196 à palavas-les-flots nous étions
gênés et en soutien enfin bref je
m'égare vous savez ce qui vous reste à
faire
des huit coulisses de touche pas à mon
poste un max d'infos sur cyril hanouna
je compte sur vous un et aux saillies je
suis là je suis rentré
bertrand bertrand chez vous pour vous
mais lloris est un peu violent je suis
toujours pas mais je suis en train de me
détendre là tu me casses les couilles
alors est-ce que vous avez ramené des
clichés alfred découvert à mais alors là
j'ai ramené un super truc
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde bah
c'est un petit selphy avec enora malagré
super sympa dont on a papoté toutes les
deux mais si c'est formidable ça sera
sûrement très plaisir à votre maman et
moi j'en ai rien à faire pour mes
affaires vous avez autre chose on vous a
raconté des anecdotes des choses sur des
asuras bouillant et de raconter des
trucs
alors isabelle morini-bosc m'a raconté
son week-end dans les ardennes avec son
mari ils sont amusés comme des fous
étonnant mais pour mes affaires
est-ce que vous avez du concret oui oui
c'est du concret j'ai rendez vous ce
soir à 21h formidable avec qui amena non
avec jean michel mr et d'ailleurs il me
dit que j'avais un très joli petit cul
tu quittes cette pièce immédiatement tu
te casses par toi c'est vrai qu'il un
jeu ridicule
obligé de se barrer du bureau pour pas
voir cette tête de con c'est quand même
triste
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui est là qu est ce qu a
clamé articulons tentant particules
rentrer c'est bon on a gagné c'est
terminé mais pas de la presse non allez
champagne pour tout bon ben qu'est ce
que tu lis là qu'est ce que tu lis
saison terminée peronne et lala a battu
lee kuan hamouma amamou ma avec 1m comme
dans ma main va ta gueule à main c'est
un joueur de foot rien à voir avec le
pakistanais des huit mohammad nas mais
c'est presque pareil on a presque gagné
20 ans a été presque viennent donc je te
conseille d'aller chercher d'autres
enfants au bureau des gages et le
champagne est le 46 on dégage web est le
problème c'est toujours le 28 mai voilà
20h55 là on est sur la préparation ça ça
va super bien
non mais j'aime pas ta gueule je préfère
camille combal à balayer cette histoire
[Applaudissements]
fabrice pendant les vacances vous avez
regardé mon 'crime times écrit que ça
avait de la gueule quoi j'étais bon la
pauvre gosse c'était rythme et bim bam
un rire toutes les 10 secondes quand
c'était bien fichu quoi pour une
première ouais mais ça va pas marcher
comme 665 me c'est pas dégueu non plus
hein bah ouais mais bon c'est quand même
moins que camille combal il a fait 913
me meek mill me fais 913 me mais en tout
cas c'était plus que le moine
ah non ça ça m'a pas mal puisque le
moine il a été plus d'un million donc
qu'est en train de me dire que de tous
les chroniqueurs de tpm pays qui ont un
prime je suis celui qui a fait le moins
d'audience ça tu le dis plus parce que
ça m'énerve ok il faut voir la
concurrence calais on avait jurassic
park en face les dirty dancing et ben
justement il fallait innover je sais pas
fallait faire danser des dinosaures j'ai
fait j'ai fait chanter régis bertrand
j'ai peut-être quelque chose quand même
cyril hanouna ne présentera pas des pmp
l'été il laisse sa place cela qui a deux
chroniques ça y est à nous le pouvoir
qu'à mes a à a
valérie bénaïm et enora malagré et je
trouve que le choix est quand même hyper
judicieux c'est bien c'est un bon choix
on n'y arriveront pas enfin vous ne
rêvez pas benjamin castaldi pourquoi
j'arrive sur nrj de rejet peut-être
parce que des huit voulait plus lui
simplement bastin